i love taking risks
love negotiating
i love
building things
from the ground up
and i'm damn good at it
and i think i love goo balls i mean it
was right there ready to go for them hey
guys pete here it's time to talk about
episode 5 of for all mankind's third
season and if this season was the only
tv i'd ever seen i'd say it was giving
me a lot of episode 3 vibes there was a
lot of build up that all led to a
thrilling final few minutes it's an
episode where when the score kicks up at
the end you're as ecstatic as everyone
at one mission control while
simultaneously being as disappointed as
everyone at the other maybe not all the
individuals in that room but definitely
the helios commander and it's an episode
that makes you wonder if he'll make good
on his promise to reduce someone to a
greasy spot on a carpet i'll get into
everything that happened after this
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched for all mankind season 3 episode
5 yet then this video won't be for you
and with that out of the way let's get
into it the episode opens with a
stunning burial at sea commander poole
cites dr martin luther king's
observation that there is democracy in
death in that we all die and concludes
by saying that death is not the end it's
only the beginning then she lets the
soviet commander say goodbye to his
fallen cosmonaut and they send the three
bodies on their final journey as the
world watches you see president ellen
wilson address the nation and since this
is now a joint mission the soviets
arrive at jsc margot welcomes the
director of ross cosmos who moves
quickly to put pressure on her of course
they know margot is compromised and even
though they said they wouldn't ask for
more circumstances have changed because
she knows that she's gonna have to go
along with the request she decides to
make her own demand that she'll only
work with sergey you learn that after
she helped them he dropped off the radar
and she tells her to get him there in
two weeks or she won't cooperate lenara
says it's not possible but she looks
like she's considering it and this is
the classic situation that once they
have you there's no way to stop them for
asking for more she really is powerless
to stop this from happening the crew on
the phoenix are able to retake control
by crashing the system to get it to
start in safe mode so that they could
roll back to the older version that
doesn't have the update that allowed deb
to take control ed sends a message that
it's his ship again and tells deb that
he dishonored their crew that inspires
karen to resign and deb doesn't want
that to happen and tries to talk her out
of it before he just gets upset and
starts threatening her this is a one-two
baldwin punch that undermines the way
deb is running the helios mission and
karen is right to push back when he says
that it was a group's decision it does
put him in a tough spot though and it'll
be interesting to see what he does in
retaliation
we do see that sojourner is able to
transfer fuel from mars 94. there are
some shots of kelly working in space and
then she has a moment with the cosmonaut
who reached out to her over the radio it
feels pretty obvious that this will all
lead somewhere and we'll see that later
in the episode daniel gets a nice
message from her son-in-law who is
supportive and says that he misses her
and that almost makes you fear for her
safety in the upcoming mission ed is
getting messages from karen and you can
see that they're both leaning into this
closeness that they have which isn't
necessarily setting them up to get back
together but it is interesting to note
that they're so drawn to each other
danny definitely notices it we see a
pretty heavy-handed shot of him that
looks ominous he's watching and then he
goes and has an awkward conversation
with nick where he fishes for
information on how to get past security
that ends with him finding out a
password he can use to get admin access
to everyone's email and of course he
starts looking at the messages that
karen sent to ed he sees that they're on
good terms and that makes him start
making the psycho crazy faces again
phoenix enters a stable mars orbit ed's
ready to prepare for landing but there
are major dust storms on the surface
that make it impossible they arrived
days ahead of sojourner but now they're
gonna have to wait until things clear up
which makes it a race again danny sends
a message to explain this to his brother
jimmy and he mentions that he's having
issues dealing with ed being his
commander at the same time on earth we
see wayne go visit karen and cook her up
a batch of humboldt county goo balls to
get her wasted it's interesting that
there are characters in both these
interactions that know the truth about
the affair that are not named ed wayne
presses karen to find out what she might
do with herself now that she's no longer
at helios and brings up that molly got
herself into painting after she left
nasa so it's good to at least hear that
molly's out there somewhere after the
goo balls kick in karen sends an
intoxicatedly excited message to ed that
really appears to get danny's blood
boiling when he watches it but at the
same time it's kind of a nice touch in
that it re-establishes what a monumental
task a trip to mars actually is
the achievement of that almost gets
diminished when you have a three-party
race so even though this scene is more
about establishing karen not knowing
what she'll do next and is brought out
through the train wreck of a character
that danny is i'm glad they added it ed
shows up at his door and orders him to
his cabin but it's just to play that
game of spades he mentioned earlier and
he wants to have a conversation as
they're talking danny turns things
towards talk about karen and it gets
unsurprisingly uncomfortable i suppose
this is to continue to build up the
tension but since that's not really been
the strongest part of things i guess the
more salvageable thing that comes from
it is that it's evident the experience
of his marriage falling apart has
changed ed's black and white thinking to
a degree and he is aware of it but he
also believes it doesn't change how he'd
react if he ever finds out who karen
slept with and it's pretty annoying that
danny's tiptoeing around this and
bringing it up while it seems even more
likely that it's going to get exposed
considering that more people than him
know about it at jsc you see that aleda
is starting to notice all the
similarities with the soviet engine she
takes her suspicions to margot who knows
the truth and knows that it's bad for
her but can buy some time to try to
deflect a lady's attention away with
everything else that's going on this
creates a complicated situation nasa and
ross cosmos have to work together to
keep their people alive margot
recognizes that elena is the future of
what she wants the agency to look like
someone to follow in her footsteps and
it makes you wonder where things will
eventually start to fall apart because
they pretty much have to the tension
there is echoed on sojourner where after
they start their burn to mars they
realize that there may have been some
damage to one of the engines in the
collision none of danielle's crew are
trained in nuclear propulsion so they
have to consider letting one of the
soviets take the lead on the brighter
side of things sergey is brought to jsc
although he's looking a lot worse for
the wear it turns out that the reason
that margot couldn't get a hold of him
after he was replaced was that he got
thrown into a kgb prison she's surprised
to find out he got tortured because she
thought things got better after
gorbachev came to power but he says
there's no controlling the kgb in a way
that makes you believe him the big news
here is that she has a plan to try to
get them both out from under their thumb
but he has good reason to be terrified
that they'll retaliate against his
family and doesn't want her to go ahead
with it things come to a head a few days
later when sojourner makes mars orbit at
mission control margo and sergey have a
nice chat to remind us how difficult it
is to land on mars and they call the
descent to seven minutes of terror at
nasa which is where the episode gets its
name
just as margot points out the thing that
everyone watching noticed that sergey is
able to smile again watching this all
play out elena interrupts because she's
made an absolutely damning discovery not
only can she prove that the soviet
engine is the same it's made worse that
she knows exactly what plans they got a
hold of alexei knows too much because he
was trained on an exact copy of their 92
engine and faced with these facts margot
can't dispute her findings again she can
buy a little more time because they're
in the middle of trying to land their
ship but she does have to tell elena
that she'll take the information she
discovered to the doj this is a
wonderfully crafted pickle because we
know all of what margot did was in the
interest of saving lives that part's not
even debatable but during the season
they put her in situations that make her
unlikable because she's making decisions
that go against what other characters we
also like want now the person that can
expose all of this is one whose motives
are also as near to pure as they could
be marcos never crossed the line of
being unsympathetic and now it almost
seems impossible for her to get out of
this situation with clean hands it seems
way more likely that she'll lose
everything and as she walks into the
little room with the telephone you see
her grapple with the weight she'll be
carrying as she tries to figure out what
to do the other great setup the show
crafted is what's happening in orbit
there's a point in that where the
commander has to make a decision on
whether the dust storm has cleared up
enough to land helios reaches that
minutes ahead of sojourner and if they
decide to pass they have to wait two
hours to try again that means there's
pressure on them to act aggressively
because they might not get the chance to
be first when they come back around we
see them thinking about the problem
independently and the two different
commanders reach two different
conclusions when they look at the data
ed asked danny if he's willing to go for
it while dany tells her crew that
they'll have to wait only she ends up
getting pressured by the soviet
commander when they see that helios has
decided to land there's a ton of tension
between them and there's a lot of little
things in how they put this together to
crank that all the way up you watch ed
and danny's craft just sort of silently
slip away while the focus is firmly on
what danielle will do we know this is
important to her we know this is
important to everybody involved and that
she should be the one who makes the
sensible and safe decision so when
things clear just enough it really slaps
you in the face when she tells them to
button up because they're going straight
in i swear sometimes it feels like this
show's cheating because these things
like going to a planet for the first
time there's just so much hell yeah
wrapped into that idea and we see things
get intense right away for popeye which
is in the lead ed remembers his time on
apollo 10 with gordo before deciding to
continue but he's losing the systems
that tell him where he is and how close
they are to the ground things are
bumpier on sojourner which lands right
on the surface rather than sending a
landing craft ahead that means the lives
of their entire crew are on the line but
they aren't running into the same
problems that helios is experiencing
when ed does get a little bit of
visibility back he sees how dangerous
their situation is and after he looks
over at danny he makes the decision to
abort he does this knowing that he's
giving up his chance to be first and
initially you think this is about saving
gordo and tracy's son but what's
probably more important here is that it
shows that he's grown as a character i
guess at this point in his life if he
were alone he would probably risk it but
also i think the old ed would have
continued regardless of whether it put
someone else at risk or not it makes it
a gut punch to see sojourner touchdown
while popeye is on its way back into
orbit because you know what's going on
in ed's head at that time but you have
to like the way he carried himself
throughout the mission plus it's kind of
fun to see the hurt look on dany's face
as danielle announces that she safely
landed eight humans at happy valley base
on the surface of mars if there has to
be winners and losers it can't be a bad
thing when commander pool comes out on
top they queue up that musical piece
that they play in all these big scenes
which by itself tends to make the eyes a
little glassy it's impossible to not get
pumped up watching everyone cheer and
hug at mission control elaine is in
charge margot remains cool but looks
satisfied and that leaves it up to
sergey to be the one who lets out a
crazy cheer it's triumphant even though
there are a lot of people who would have
been there in previous seasons missing
it wraps up with sergey and margot
having a moment where she tells him not
to worry because she will figure out a
way to keep his family safe before going
over to congratulate elena at helios deb
looks devastated as does bill who has to
be missing nasa in this moment and we
even see debs partner richard hilliard
make his first appearance as he watches
his reaction to the bad news at home
karen watches it play out she's
disappointed for ed but proud of kelly
while being relieved that they're both
still alive at the white house president
wilson sets the stage with mikhail
gorbachev at her side she talks about
the partnership and working together and
that sets up the somewhat comical ending
where you see that the soviet commander
has a plan to get to the surface first
he essentially starts to make a break
for it while danielle's prepping the
crew so when it's time to see this
historic moment on television it ends
with her grabbing him in an attempt to
catch up so that they both tumble onto
the surface at the same time as you hear
the announcer saying how inspiring and
the episode ends there
it's another example of for all mankind
doing what it does best there isn't much
more to say about it you don't need to
feel too sorry for ed since given the
circumstances i don't think he'll be
second guessing himself this time it's
probably setting up a showdown between
him and dev but that seemed pretty
inevitable either way danny will
probably continue to danny things up but
again there was probably no stopping
that kelly and alexei have a full-blown
cross-culture love affair brewing it's
still a little early to say where that
will lead but i'm sure it won't be a
small part of what happens now that
they're on the planet it feels a little
silly to say it out loud but she's there
to discover life and she might also end
up playing a part in creating it i
thoroughly enjoyed this episode the
highs were high enough to make me forget
about the lows i guess that gives me a
little bit of concern when i wonder
about how they could continue to top
these big moments week after week but we
can cross that bridge when we get to it
overall the last couple of minutes felt
like a finale in that the race is over
but we're only halfway through the
season i'm dreading margo's fall but
beyond that the future is looking pretty
bright with mars getting a lot more
crowded when the crew of helios joins
the party i can't wait to see what
happens next and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought of the episode
how you feel about the race now that
it's all over and what you're hoping to
see now that they're on the surface of
mars please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon